the ultimate sacrifice sukuna shocking
death and yuji's insane new cursed
technique Jujutsu Kaizen is absolutely
going off right now and G isn't pulling
any punches we need to talk about what
just happened we need to talk about that
twist in the end so let's get into it
you guys know how this works if you
enjoy my jjk videos you want to see more
in the future leave a quick like and
comment right now for that YouTube
algorithm and if you want to help this
channel attain special grade status by
hitting 2 million subscribers do me a
huge favor and subscribe right now we
are less than 10K subscribers away from
2 million we're so close finally this
video will of course contain jjk manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned in the previous
chapter there was an allout war between
sukun on the one side and yui higuma
kusakabe choso and Eno on the other
sukuna noticed that all the sorcerers
had gotten stronger and he was impressed
by their ability to improve so much in
such a short period of time but at the
same time Sugo was still dominating the
fight despite it being 5- on1 sukuna
managed to seriously injure choso after
choso tried to attack him and he also
effectively dealt with all the attacks
initiated by the other sorcerers in what
turned out to be a bit of foreshadowing
we learned that Eno's blade had been
imbued with nanami's curse technique
which made Eno's attack a lot more
powerful than sukuna had expected but
again this wasn't enough to actually
threaten sukuna and in the end we saw
Yuji racing to stop sukuna from hunting
down higuma preventing sukuna from
killing hiur was extremely important
because suuma and his curse technique
were the best hope that the sorcerers
had of actually defeating sukuna that's
because the Executioner sword has the
power to kill anyone even sukuna and yet
at the same time it only harms those who
have been judged guilty and given a
death sentence this means that the
Executioner sword would kill sukuna
without actually harming megumi's Soul
so this could literally be the only way
of defeating sukuna without seriously
harming megumi in the process the end of
the chapter went out of it it way to
emphasize what an incredible natural
Talent higuma is as a sorcerer even
though he first became a sorcerer less
than two months ago he has shown
extraordinary growth and even sukuna was
highly impressed by huruma power and
potential in fact after higuma was able
to learn domain amplification on the
spot in order to neutralize sukuna
technique higuma Talent was said to be
equal to satarug Gojo's which as we know
is incredibly High Praise Gojo had his
entire life to perfect his skills and
master his curse technique and of course
he had the six eyes and yet higuma was
able to accomplish so much in less than
2 months unfortunately for higuma the
latest chapter showed that Talent is not
the only thing that he and Gojo have in
common the latest chapter again calls
huruma a Jujutsu genius and sukuna
acknowledges that higuma Master of his
cursed technique is at a similar level
to his own we all know that is insanely
High Praise coming from sukuna and he
even does higuma the honor of referring
to him directly by his name he uruma
hiromi but then sukuna initiates some
kind of earthquake jutu that turns the
entire Battlefield into rubble and
before you know it higuma and Yuji are
again struggling against sukuna in a
desperate two-on-one sukuna manages to
land a web of slashes on Yuji and as
Yuji falls to the ground bleeding
profusely sukuna mocks him yet again the
king of curses tells Yuji that he is a
boar and that there isn't a single
interesting bone in his body I find it
quite intriguing that sukuna keeps going
out of his way to point out that Yugi
isn't anyone special and that his
existence means absolutely nothing to
sukuna it's almost like sukuna is
emphasizing this point a little too much
does sukuna know something about Yuji
that we don't and is he actually
belittling Yuji in this way as a coping
mechanism because he knows that in
reality Yuji is special I mean he is
literally a human experiment created and
birthed by Kaku himself so there's no
way that Yuji is just some random
uninteresting nobody I think sukuna has
it out for yuji's specifically because
he knows that Yuji is special in some
way but that's just my gut feeling what
do you guys think let me know down in
the comments and of course don't forget
to like And subscribe to put some
respect on our boy yuji's name after
Yuji is temporarily taken out of the
game by sukuna higuma tries to hold his
own using the Executioner sword but it
is extremely difficult and sukuna is
clearly the one controlling the fight
after landing some blows on higuma
sukuna ends up severing the lawyer's
right arm then as a leading higuma
struggles to stay on his feet sukuna
tells him to go on and heal himself the
last chapter reminded us that higuma
does not know how to use reverse curse
technique to heal his injuries at least
not yet but sukuna is determined to test
the full extent of this man's potential
by forcing him to unlock RCT right now
in real time sukuna then proceeds to cut
off higuma other arm and now higuma
doesn't even have possession of the
Executioner sword anymore because the
sword drops down to the ground along
with his severed hand sukuna then gos
higuma telling him that if he doesn't
learn to use reverse curse technique
right now he will lose his head as well
and this will be the end for him as the
lawyer contemplates his role in this
fight and the prospect of dying at the
hands of sukuna the king of curses is
attacked by another piercing blood
attack although we don't see the
attacker sukuna suggests that the attack
came from the older cursed womb death
painting brother choso and he calls him
stubborn this means that despite being
severely injured in the previous chapter
choso is still alive at least for now
unless that attack actually came from
Yuji who somehow managed to learn Choo's
piercing blood technique given yuji's
recent physical transformation we know
that he has some sort of power up that
we are yet to fully witness but is the
ability to use Choo's blood manipulation
a part of that PowerUp or is it
something else altogether from this
chapter alone it is not clear yet but
overall that piercing blood attack was
little more than a a brief distraction
for sukuna because he ends up blocking
it quite easily and yet that brief
distraction was enough for higuma to
awaken his reverse curse technique he
regenerates his arms like a freaking
Titan shifter from Attack on Titan and
pierces sua's hand with the Executioner
sword higuma thinks this must be it the
legendary executioner sword has made
contact with sukuna flesh and the sword
can kill anyone it touches so that means
that sukuna must be about to die now
right well no it was never never going
to be that easy and we all knew it as it
turns out just before higuma managed to
pierce sukuna hand sukuna managed to cut
off his hand which presumably negated
the effects of the Executioner sword on
his body now if you're asking yourself
wouldn't it be easier for sukuna to just
dodge the attack instead of going
through the trouble of cutting his own
hand off don't worry I'm asking myself
that too but this method does have a lot
more flare so there's that in that
moment higuma realizes that he failed to
defeat sukuna and that he is about to
die but but he also finally comes to
understand his true role in this battle
as kusakabe said to him earlier it is
possible that curses get stronger after
death and maybe the same goes for a
cursed technique like judgment and so
higuma decides that he must die right
here and now but before he dies he
manages to transfer his own curse
technique on to Yuji on top of that as
Yuji rejoins the battle and appears
behind sukuna higuma manages to throw
the Executioner sword over to y
then much like nanami higuma says that
he's done what he can and Yuji has got
it from here then in a massive twist we
see Yuji seemingly stabbing sukuna in
the back from behind with The
Executioner's sword higuma appears to
have sacrificed his life but in return
Yuji managed to kill sukuna sukuna is
totally definitely dead now right guys G
is definitely not going to pull another
reverse Uno on us with sukuna like he
did so many times four right right I
mean G does like to subvert our
expectations but I still fully expect
sukuna to survive this either he will
Dodge at the last moment or he has some
other trick up his sleeve but even with
higuma sacrifice there is no way that
sukunai is going to go down so easily
that said I am fascinated by the fact
that higuma was seemingly able to
transfer his curse technique and the
Executioner sword over to Yuji even
after his apparent death like did he
make some kind of binding vow in order
to do this a binding vow that required
higuma to die at the hands of sukuna for
the vow to actually be completed or is
higuma actually still alive this chapter
sure set it up as if heura just
sacrificed his life we even had that
little nanami moment but maybe G is
deliberately misleading us yet again I
mean higuma literally just awakened his
ability to use reverse curse technique
so he might be about to use it again to
survive being cut down by sukuna
whatever happens to the lawyer guy this
was an incredibly intense chapter and
this stuff about potentially trans
transing your curse technique onto
someone else is a huge deal even if it
can only be done after the original
user's death like imagine if Gojo
somehow managed to transfer his curse
technique to someone else like UTA that
would be absolutely broken beyond belief
so yeah the idea that something like
this is even possible is absolutely
crazy okay quick question for you guys
if you could pick one sorcerer in the
story to transfer his technique to
another sorcerer who would you pick Gojo
to Utah kosimo to hakari which power
combination would be the coolest let me
know right now also do you think higuma
is really dead do you think Yuji
wielding the Executioner sword could
actually kill sukuna can the Executioner
sword Grant new powers to Yuji the likes
of which we haven't seen before leave
your feedback down below I can't wait to
see what happens next and I'd love to
see what you guys think will happen now
if you're looking for an epic jjk video
to watch next check out this video where
I cope hard about Gojo and talk about
why he's totally not really dead you
guys link on screen and in the
description if you enjoy this video and
you want to see more in the future leave
a quick like to let me know and if you
want to help this channel attain special
grade status by hitting 2 million
subscribers do me a huge favor and
subscribe right now subscribing on
YouTube is completely free and we are
less than 10K away from 2 million